ce soit on va à chambly la ville du
bonheur
du moins en apparence comment comprendre
le boss c'est denis lavoie maire de la
municipalité de la banlieue sud de
montréal depuis plus de dix ans
seulement il se prend pour le roi
dans une conversation téléphonique
enregistrée à son insu on découvre
comment le maire utilise parfois son
pouvoir plus m'occuper
mais tout est encore plus on est pas mal
proche lob de procéder contrôler les
états dictatoriaux
il n'hésite pas à faire appel aux
avocats pour défendre sa réputation
celle de sa ville faire valoir ses
droits ou faire taire ses détracteurs
il me semble que c'est une attaque est
la liberté d'expression un maire agir de
cette façon là c'est la fiction elle
n'avait plus la guerre non mais tu as
vécu dans la marre de te parler
bienvenue à enquête
je
[Musique]
le 21 septembre à chambly une marche
silencieuse pour défendre la liberté
d'expression est sur le point de
commencer
depuis environ un an le torchon brûle
entre certains citoyens et la ville et
ceux qui osent critiquer les décisions
du maire et de son conseil le font à
leurs risques et périls pour la première
fois il accepte de se confier à visage
découvert un immédiat
ça fait trente trois ans que j'habite la
ville de chambly
l'écriture c'est ça fait partie de la
liberté d'expression et c'est quelque
chose de fondamental pour moi
louise chevrier et son mari raymond
ostiguy ont une retraite active
il milite au sein du mouvement citoyens
de chambly un organisme qui lutte pour
la transparence municipal on veut être
informé sur les dons si on veut savoir
pourquoi la ville prend certaines
décisions au printemps dernier louis
chevrier rédige une lettre d'opinion
dans laquelle elle s'oppose un
changement de nom de rue décrétée par la
ville et elle reprend des propos
attribués au maire dans un journal local
le maire de chambly a fustigé les
citoyens qui n'approuve pas les
changements groupuscule hargneux gens
intolérants et à partir de lever tout a
déboulé quelques semaines plus tard elle
reçoit par huissier une mise en demeure
la ville estime que le contenu de sa
lettre publiée par impératif français
portent atteinte à sa réputation et à
celle de son maire cette fausse
allégation déconsidère le maire et la
ville et leur font perdre l'estimé et la
considération de vos lecteurs vous
prêter aux maires des propos très
péjoratif de surcroît il les a jamais
prononcé la ville lui reproche aussi
d'avoir influencé l'opinion publique
vos fausses allégations avaient eu un
impact auprès de certains citoyens de la
ville de chambly
suite à la lecture de votre article ils
ont modifié leur position
il ya quelque chose qui me choque
beaucoup dans cette mise en damas c'est
que on ici
après avoir lu mon opinion certaines
personnes ont changé d'idée
alors que au départ ils étaient de
l'avis de la ville pourtant c'est
vraiment ça un débat public à s'il me
semble que c'est une attaque à la
liberté d'expression
ce propos la la ville lui exige des
excuses dans les 48 heures et la somme
de 2500 $ à titre de dommages
une démarche qui aura coûté 4000 $ à la
municipalité
c'est incroyable ça faut pas exagérer si
on peut plus dire ça dans la place
publique c'est grave
alors non je vais pas m'excuser le 21
septembre dernier
dominick béland participe elle aussi à
la marche silencieuse du mouvement
citoyens de chambly un organisme qu'elle
a fondé avec d'autres dont louis
chevrier depuis le début de l'année la
ville a fait parvenir au moins cinq
mises en demeure dont deux sont devenus
des poursuites à des citoyens pour des
commentaires jugés diffamatoires
[Musique]
dominick béland est poursuivi par la
ville pour des propos tenus sur les
réseaux sociaux
elle fait partie de ceux qui réclament
la diffusion sur internet des séances du
conseil municipal
j'ai été vraiment très très surprise
voici les propos qu'on lui reproche dans
la poursuite en plus de ses nombreuses
magouilles
le maire cache aussi son attitude
méprisante et irrespectueuse lors des
conseils municipaux en se battant contre
la webdiffusion pour ne pas que ces
agissements soient mises à jour
la ville de chambly considère que ces
allégations sont diffamatoires et lui
reprochent notamment l'utilisation du
mot magouilles qui à son avis signifie
des actions malhonnêtes contrevenant à
la loi
et pour ça on me demandait de 25000
dollars et aussi de signer une lettre d'
excuses où on me demanda en gros de
faire la carpette l'eau sont heureux
alors c'est fait pour museler pour
balayer les citoyens et c'est totalement
inacceptable
mais moi j'ai rien vu là d'un qui
dépassent ce qui est généralement
considéré comme acceptable ou tolérable
dans le contexte du débat politique
pierre trudel et professeur de droit
il est un ardent défenseur de la liberté
d'expression
nous lui avons soumis des mises en
demeure et poursuite de la ville de
chambly dans celle de louis chevrier et
dominick béland
ce qui me semble encore plus inquiétant
c'est que ça se termine pour la plupart
par une demande
faites aux citoyens de signer un
document dans lequel ils déclarent
qu'ils se sont trompés ils ont eu tort
sorte d' apostasie
un peu comme on faisait dans le temps de
l'inquisition au moyen âge alors là
vraiment on est plus dans le domaine de
l'intimidation que dans le domaine de la
défense de la réputation
[Musique]
mais est ce vraiment nécessaire de
sortir l'artillerie pour protéger la
réputation du maire de cette ville riche
en histoires le maire a refusé de nous
accorder une entrevue blâmant l'ensemble
de notre démarche journalistique dans un
courriel
il nous explique que la liberté
d'expression ne signifie pas le droit de
diffamer librement les missions de mise
en demeure à des citoyens n'est pas une
mesure qui a été prise de gaieté de
coeur
elle s'est toutefois avéré nécessaire
suite aux nombreux abus de la part d'un
groupuscule politique mais content mais
questionné l'an dernier sur l'envoi
d'une mise en demeure
il nous avait donné cette réponse je
t'avoue que tu as les et qu'une mise en
demeure
c'est comme demander s'il ne nous jette
à lait et du miel selon des documents
que nous avons obtenu les deux récentes
poursuites dans celle de dominick béland
et cinq mises en demeure envoyée par la
ville ont coûté au moins 57 mille
dollars aux contribuables de chambly
car d'une partie se sert des fonds
publics pour faire taire ses concitoyens
on est pas mal proche de procéder qu'on
retrouve nalliers d'aller dans les états
dictatoriaux ème année je voulais faire
un accueil ce qu'ont bien ça me coûte
d'avocats pour les procédures que nous
il paraît que nous aurons des
contribuables on paye
robert pots-de-vin un ancien policier
sait à quel point denis lavoie peut être
vite sur la gâchette
quand vient le temps d'envoyer une mise
en demeure la première fois que j'ai
côtoyés denis lavoie c'était quand on
jouait pour la ligue de balle molle et
vétérans chambly en état d'un même
équipe cet incident survient il ya une
dizaine d'années denis lavoie bien
qu'impliqué en politique n'est pas
encore maire de chambly mais il est sur
le point de devenir moi je vois au
troisième but lui joie au champ gauche
ont marre l équipe adverse monde notre
antenne balle dans son champ à lui pat
l'adni avare bal avec le chili à devenir
un manager mais n'a mal parce que nous y
gab à bas le facteur du délit est ch'ti
à la mène la balle laclotte tout pareil
parce que cris tellement par le monde un
premier incident des témoins de l'époque
nous rapporte de vifs échanges entre les
deux hommes
à plusieurs reprises par la suite ce qui
était au départ de simples prises de bec
prend de l'ampleur
mais l'uci que nous
libérez le la mise en demeure de
monsieur mon épouse joanne qui répondait
à pat lam a rejoint robert pas devant
nous explique que denis lavoie lui
réclame dix mille dollars en guise de
dédommagement pour les incidents parce
que monsieur est un homme public d'abord
français j'avais ainsi des homos mais
pour le maire denis lavoie la mise en
demeure est un moyen utile et efficace
une mise en demeure le moyen privilégié
est la première étape pour le résoudre
sereinement
[Musique]
finalement sa mise en demeure est restée
lettre morte dans son cas précis il
estime que denis lavoie avocat de
formation s'est servi d'un canon pour
tuer une mouche
c'est là bas il se prend pour le roi 4
suivi son cours de droit
le chapitre 2 le plus adoré probablement
s'est échappé de la mise des mises en
demeure c'est pas croyable
après la pause les colère du maire ça
brasse à chambly
[Musique]
était 2015
l'une des équipes féminines du club
d'arsenal de chambly enchaîne les
victoires
l'atmosphère est à la fête carole
laroche garde un excellent souvenir de
l'équipe dans sa fille fait alors partie
on avait une sphère de bonnes équipes en
étaient les meilleurs
les filles étaient les meilleurs elle se
souvient aussi de l'entraîneur qui se
donnait quand rien c'était un passionné
comme quand ce n'est pas un jour denis
lavoie contacter les responsables du
cube
il est mécontente du traitement réservé
à sa fille elle aussi membre de l'équipe
denis lavoie se plaignait que sa fille a
joué assez souvent
puis que l'entraîneur avait lancé dans
le visage de sa vie denis lavoie réclame
donc ni plus ni moins que le
congédiement de l'entraîneur il en fait
part à benoist girard l'un des
responsables de l'arsenal de chant bible
ce mordu de soccer est impliqué dans le
sport amateur depuis des années
agacé par l'intervention du maire il
décide d'enregistrer sa conversation
avec lui c'est quoi qui en fait
l'entraîneur qui fait en sorte que ça
lag si loin xo qui régit les de la tâche
de ma fille 3 politique et je ne
mangeais plus loin que je réponde
négociations besoin je te lis prix
ménages et bovines et le changement ces
deux villes vous allez la voir
nous sommes prêts à des négociations
mais moi qui prescrivent usa d'avant
match quasi parfait
il va être exporté avec des symboles qui
la madeleine et à parler
dans l'entente avec la ville est ce que
ça dit le maire ont un droit de regard
sur vos décisions non le maire aucun
droit de regard son audition mais
s'implique dans nos éditions mois la
tradition comédie jetait pour leur
raconter voir qu'est ce qu'ils en
étaient 2 qu'est ce qui s'est passé 10h
et à leur comble non nous n'en est pas
là on n'est pas là mais moi je t'ai dit
que j'avais pas parler que je le mettais
des avantages et des choix le rencontrer
avant konaté pour mon bonheur
elle comprend qu un manque de classe
dans une classe juste à bien pire
moi je pense que c'est pau c'est pas
digne d'aval jamais le poids pas les
plus beaux que les compagnies d'europe
et d'ailleurs jamais jamais jamais je
veux donner les mêmes communes appelées
via mon personnel manas denis oui il y
en a qui me l'a fait après un moment
donné la conversation prend une autre
tournure entre benoît girard et denis
lavoie
le maire fait alors référence à son
intervention pour chasser un groupe de
motards d'un local de la ville
plus beaux faits mais tu étais encore
fait quelques pas de moule ou non plus
je parle pour l'entraînement j'ai 57 ans
j'ai été dans sport pendant 30 ans j'ai
jamais reçu un marc agir de cette façon
là de discuter de cette façon-là de
servir son poids politique de cette
façon là c'est rosa fiction carrément en
raison des pressions du maire le club
trouve un prétexte pour congédier
l'entraîneur
nous l'avons contacté pour obtenir sa
version des faits il prétend qu'il n'a
jamais lancé de dossard au visage de la
jeune fille
il n'a pas voulu nous donner une
entrevue redoutant des représailles
de son côté le maire écrit que le
congédiement de l'entraîneur était la
décision du club et que son rôle est de
protéger les enfants
on n'avait pas à le congédier dans mon
corps je l'avais pas congédier nous
avons soumis l'enregistrement à un
ancien ministre des affaires municipales
rémy trudel et professeur à l'inrs ap
il s'intéresse aux questions d'éthique
et de gouvernance des organisations
publiques seraient convenus d'un abus de
pouvoir
chose à peine un cheval ça s'appelle
l'appui de l'autorité je me sers de mon
autorité pour intervenir de façon
autoritaire dans un autre chat de
compétences
[Musique]
la ville de chambly avec ces quelques
trente mille habitants compte dans ses
rangs des ambassadeurs qui se passe de
présentation
j'ai choisi cette ville oeil au trentin
et gelard choisi à chaque jour l'homme
d'affaires animateurs et cuisinier fait
partie de la toute nouvelle campagne de
la ville intitulé fier de vivre à
chambly les gens sont beaux je redis
ville un décor enchanteur
un lieu où il fait bon vivre mais selon
plusieurs le climat de travail à l'hôtel
de ville
contraste avec l'image que veut projeter
la municipalité la localité qui
s'affichait jusqu'à tout récemment comme
la ville du bonheur porterait bien mal
son nom
les gens ayant un portrait de l'homme
politique beau sourire belle image tout
seul mais quand tu travailles
quotidiennement le pq tu vois ça allez
une petite chute dans un milieu toxique
il faut que j'en sorte moi j'ai fait le
choix de passer à la mater jeta pas prêt
pour la retraite au cours des derniers
mois nous avons parlé avec de nombreux
excès actuels employés de la ville de
chambly
la plupart nous parle d'un climat de
travail tendue malsain ou même toxiques
deux anciens prennent aujourd'hui leur
courage à deux mains pour dénoncer la
situation
lorsque monsieur lavoie est devenu
majoritaire
ça commençait se détériore arrive il y
avait vraiment un avant et un après
avant et après les élections de 2009
selon l'ex employé de chambly rené
gauvreau a travaillé au service des
finances de la ville pendant huit ans
moi je commence à avoir des signes
au niveau de ma santé qui fait que je
rentre le matin je trouve la porte vu
rouge et des montagnes du mal au coeur
il quitte en 2015 parce qu'il n'en peut
plus du climat de travail m'ont donné je
raisonne pas choisi je peux plus
continuer avery d'as2 minul a pu
continuer rapide et mama situation santé
claire adam a travaillé comme secrétaire
pour la ville de chambly pendant 25 ans
de 1991 à 2016
elle dit avoir été témoin à de
nombreuses reprises de colère de la part
du maire j'ai été trois un jeu sans
titre son bureau à l'huile son cabinet
et souvent on l'entendait poche et crié
ensuite il descendait les escaliers
aller voir la greffière
il criait c'est vraiment insupportable
j'ai vu des personnes sortir du bureau
l'ampleur a démoli complètement les
témoignages de claire adam et rené
gauvreau recoupe les propos de la
majorité des employés et ex-employés à
qui nous avons pu parler plusieurs
allègue avoir été victime
d'intimidations de la part du maire le
harcèlement conçu sous forme de menaces
semaine pas attendue aussi il nous dit
ta taille de vos roulis par crainte de
représailles
ils nous ont demandé de protéger leur
identité c'est très sûr noir le maire
fait souvent référence à d'autres
personnes qui réussit à congédier pour
montrer que tu pourrait subir le même
sort sa phrase magique c'est tel
avantage à être d'accord avec moi sinon
on va avoir un problème j'ai vu des
collègues qui sortent en pleurs après
avoir rencontré le maire
pour moi c'est pas la ville du bonheur
c'est la ville de la terreur
le maire se défend de toutes les
allégations d'intimidation à son endroit
j'accorde fait une très grande
importance à l'instauration d'un climat
de travail positif est sain il peut
certainement sept produits que parfois
j'intervienne avec vigueur mais toujours
dans l'objectif de mieux servir les
citoyens
il n'y a jamais eu de plainte à mon
égard pour cause de comportement abusif
pourquoi les gens se plaignent pas
davantage moi j'ose dire c'est la peur
de cela poursuit on n'a pas de recevoir
des mises en demeure se parlent est ce
que ce sera quand même ce milieu lancer
des employés et ex-employés nous disent
que la relation qu'entretient le maire
avec cette directrice générale adjointe
contribuent au climat malsain à l'hôtel
de ville
la fonctionnaire a ni neptune est aussi
trésorière et responsable des ressources
humaines
ils ont été vus ensemble à l'extérieur
des heures de travail à maintes reprises
notamment lors du repêchage de la ligue
de hockey junior majeur du québec un
événement télédiffusée pour plusieurs
cette proximité pose problème pour nous
annie nepton et denis lavoie
c'est la même personne je peux pas
dénoncé l'un à l'autre il se pensant le
soir et le directeur général est
accessoire comment voulez vous que les
employés dénoncent une situation si la
mairie la direction générale les
finances et des ressources humaines sont
sous l'autorité d'un couple
tout comme annie nepton denis lavoie
évoque le respect de la vie privée et un
avis légal qu'il refuse de partager avec
nous aucune obligation légale et éthique
ou autre ne m'oblige à faire et todd
d'une quelconque relation avec une
employée de la ville
je n'ai de compte à rendre à personne
quand à savoir avec qui j'ai envie de
voir le soleil de crue mais l'an dernier
il avait dû répondre à des questions sur
cette relation dans le cadre d'une cause
entendue devant le tribunal du travail
êtes vous un couple avec eni neptune la
réponse non comment décririez vous votre
relation
deux personnes adultes de 57 ans madame
nepton à son condo mais elle ne demande
pas avec moi c'est une amie proche c'est
pas quelqu'un que je déteste
andré lacroix et professeur d'éthique
politique à l'université de sherbrooke
où s'arrête la vie privée les vie privée
s'arrête avant s'arrête là où ça qu elle
commence à nuire à votre fonction
publique
voilà la fonction vous occupez donc en
d'autres termes est-ce que c'est
d'intérêt public
le pur de commencer anomie les relations
que ni l'ue peut avoir avec tel personne
non est-ce que c'est d'intérêt public
l'a nommé si cette relation engendre
possible conflit d'intérêts oui c'est
d'intérêt public on est en pleine de
conflits d'apparence 10h tous ces gars
là le maire estime que les
fonctionnaires qui veulent porter
plainte ont l'embarras du choix
ils peuvent s'adresser entre autres au
syndicat des cols blancs et des cols
bleus qui ont tous deux décliné une
demande d'entrevue
de son côté claire adam lance un cri du
coeur que je pense à ceux et celles qui
sont là actuellement au travail comme
employés municipaux qui aimerait bien
parler son programme dolphin minsk pour
se tenir debout parce que sauf faut que
ça arrête
pour sa part annie neptune estime que le
climat à la ville est très dynamique et
stimulant et que le service des
ressources humaines est ouvert à tous
elle ajoute qu'il n'ya aucune plein de
quelque nature que ce soit quant au
directeur général
il ne rapporte aucune plainte de
harcèlement ni aucun qui m'a mal 5 il
n'a que de bons mots pour madame neptune
et le maire qu'il considère comme un
mentor nani cannetois la nacam benoist
girard du club de soccer l'arsenal de
chambly a longuement réfléchi avant de
rendre public l'enregistrement trois ans
de réflexion trois ans de discussions
faut déclarer ces situations là il faut
les dévoiler parce que c'est un polar
denis lavoie a été élu en novembre
dernier pour un quatrième mandat
consécutif
avec plus de 56% des voix son meilleur
résultat depuis 2005
pour rémy trudel la situation à chambly
est préoccupante mais à son avis ce sont
les électeurs qui au bout du compte
auront le dernier mot restait qui
inquiète le changement il faut espérer
c'est le charmant du peuple mais dites
vous bien de choses
l'avenir dure longtemps mais les
citoyens sont toujours présents et un
jour ou l'autre il faut répondre
heureusement des gestes et d'édition
complet
j'espère que vous avez apprécié de
reportages de ce soir au nom de toute
l'équipe
merci beaucoup d'avoir été là et revenez
nous la semaine prochaine pour une autre
enquête
[Musique]